hopefully you know this already but
that's a toothbrush so are these and the
one thing they have in common they're
all plastic but here's something you
might not know this routine has been
around for a millennia and back then
they used chewing sticks fast forward a
bit to 1498 china they used a bamboo
handle and some hog hair but here's the
thing one estimate says 1 billion
toothbrushes are ending up here every
year in the US and that sounds bad but
we might be able to change that now
let's go meet a dentist I'm dr. Scott
Swank Dennis I've been practicing for 30
years but Scott isn't just any dentist
I'm currently the curator at the
National Museum of Dentistry in
Baltimore Maryland this is George
Washington's lower denture these are
dental scalars fit for a queen these
were actually owned by Queen Victoria
this is the Swiss Army knife of tooth
extraction devices brushing your teeth
became important during the Civil War
men were being disqualified for service
because they didn't have two opposing
back teeth and they needed those in
order to tear open paper rifle and
musket cartridges
so here's what that looks like and
that's pretty hard to do if you don't
have teeth but here was the problem with
that toothbrushes hadn't really caught
on yet in America by 1924 only about 20%
of Americans brush their teeth which is
gross and then the DuPont company
excused
nylon the American public in the late
1930s and boom the very first nylon
bristle toothbrush then came World War
two it was during the war that the army
decided to give every soldier a
toothbrush and make it a mandatory part
of their daily routine and that
toothbrush design it hasn't really
changed since this is Charlotte vo f ie
LL and it's pronounced Fjell she's a
leading expert on design and has written
a lot of books
including this one on the history of
plastics it was a fascinating journey
because I didn't realize what an
incredible history it had in the future
we have to use plastics more
thoughtfully when you actually think
about them they're incredibly noble
precious materials there's no reason why
something that's made of plastic can't
last a lifetime the answer really for
months at least according to the a da so
with 300 million Americans that's 1.2
billion toothbrushes being thrown away
just in America that's enough to wrap
around the world four times
now let's look ahead if you're a
designer you have an absolute duty to
design properly especially especially if
they're using plastics because plastics
might be cheap materials but they
actually have a very high impact on the
environment they're very expensive
materials when you actually think of
them in a holistic way
okay so here's some options we could use
alternative materials bone metal recycle
plastic or bamboo could work there are
toothbrushes with replaceable heads and
then there's pig hair which biodegrades
but it wouldn't be an option for vegans
and people with certain religious
beliefs lastly chewing sticks created
from the neem tree are a totally plastic
free option but that would be a huge
cultural shift change takes time and
because we've been using the same
toothbrush design for about 70 years
maybe that time is now
[Music]
[Music]